hello and thank you my name is Oscar
villadel I'm Lieutenant with the Texas
Department of Public Safety as we begin
today I'm going to go and introduce our
speakers first will be Chief Brian
Harvey with the Allen Police Department
then we will have special agent in
charge of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation Chad Yarbrough and then
summary summarizing things at the end
will be our regional director Hank
Sibley with the Texas Department of
Public Safety before we begin our
Spanish translation
well when this community was attacked on
May 6th the Allen Police Department
responded along with many others from
the north Texas law enforcement
community
that included both police and fire our
community also responded with an
overwhelming show of support for the
victims the victims families and Public
Safety and we are grateful and thank you
one particular officer distinguished
himself in an exemplary manner
demonstrating tremendous bravery when he
immediately addressed an attacker that
was injuring and murdering innocent
victims
we know our community would like to
thank and honor him
however we're not prepared to release
that officer's name due to the ongoing
investigation
and the officer has also expressed his
appreciation for his privacy as he
continues to process this tragic event
there were many other heroic life-saving
efforts conducted by our officers and
the fire department
we plan to recognize them in the future
and we also must acknowledge The Bravery
of Allied security guard Christian
liqueur
who evacuated one individual to safety
and was shot while courageously
remaining to help others
the immediate support
of multiple local County state and
federal agencies is so numerous it will
be challenging to thank each one
individually
each one of them was critical to the
safe evacuation of the site and
stabilization efforts thanks to the
Swift assistance of all these agencies
we have now officially concluded the
actions at the Allen Premium Outlets and
turned the site back over to Property
Management
the reopening of the stores at the
outlets will be determined by management
and store owners
we know our Island community and many
many others are feeling the Deep weight
of grief from this tragedy
and we are heartbroken over the eight
victims that were lost
the others who were wounded
and the hundreds of people who
experience this traumatic event
firsthand
members of our department
and victim Services units from the FBI
Department of Public Safety and the
Collin County District Attorney's office
will continue to work closely with
members of our community who are
requesting victims and or mental health
services
in the coming days
members of the police department will
continue to work closely with the FBI
DPS and Texas Rangers to thoroughly
investigate this tragedy
we relied heavily on the agencies here
today the Department of Public Safety
Texas Rangers and the Federal Bureau of
Investigation
my request to you today as the media is
to continue to help publicize our victim
Counseling and Family Assistance fund
those two opportunities that can make a
tremendous difference in these
individuals lives and it is listed on
the Allen City website
at this time I'd like to turn it over to
the FBI special agent in charge Chad
Yarbrough thank you
good afternoon my name is Chad Yarbrough
I'm the special agent in charge of the
Dallas FBI field office
first and foremost on behalf of the FBI
I want to begin by expressing my deepest
condolences to the victims to the
families and loved ones of those
murdered and injured in this vicious
attack this past Saturday at the Allen
Premium Outlets we recognize the fear
and heartache that occurs when heinous
acts of violence are committed and the
devastating impact it has on the people
and the community
since our arrival to the scene on
Saturday the FBI has devoted significant
resources to assist in the investigation
of what occurred in Allen
those resources include investigative
Personnel intelligence digital forensics
and victim Services just to name a few
the FBI is currently analyzing
electronic devices and digital media
connected to the suspect at our North
Texas regional computer forensic
Laboratory
there's still a lot to be done in this
investigation and we will continue to
thoroughly review this material and
share
when the investing with the
investigative team
the FBI's victim Services response team
has been deployed with over 20 specially
trained Personnel to work and
collaborate alongside the Allen Police
Department the Texas Department of
Public safeties victims services and the
Collin County District Attorney's office
as well as other state and Community
organizations to provide essential
support and assistance to those impacted
by this unimaginable tragedy
strong well-established relationships
with our law enforcement partners
and community members have been
indispensable to this response and
investigation and we cannot thank our
partners enough for their steadfast
commitment and unyielding efforts to
help others
as of yesterday the victim Services team
and Community Partners have been able to
provide resources and services to over
30 families which consists to over 100
individuals and over the past two days
FBI personnel and Community Partners
have escorted close to 1100 people to
retrieve their abandoned vehicles into
parking lots in the vicinity of the
shooting
if you were present on Saturday at the
Allen Premium Outlets we encourage you
to visit the Family Assistance Center at
the Allen senior Recreational Center at
451 St Mary drive here in Allen
in addition personal effects that we
that were left outside the retail stores
have been collected and can also be
retrieved at this location
it will be open today and tomorrow from
10 a.m until 7 pm
victims are not just those who are
physically injured but also those who
were present and may be experiencing
emotional distress
we ask that you continue to respect the
privacy of the victims affected by this
tragedy
we are aware of multiple fake online
fundraisers that are currently underway
for the victims
please properly vet any charity or
fundraiser before donating money to
ensure that it reaches the proper
victims and there's a list of those in
uh properly vetted
Charities on the Allen website we are
also still seeking information from the
public if you are at the Allen Premium
Outlets and have information we ask that
you please call 1-800 call FBI
our focus in the coming days will
continue to be providing Aid and comfort
to our victims as well as working with
our law enforcement Partners on the
criminal investigation that is ongoing
our thoughts and prayers continue to be
with all those who have been so severely
impacted by this terrible tragedy thank
you
good afternoon my name is Hank Sibley I
am the north Texas regional director for
the Texas Department of Public Safety
first I'd like to express the
condolences on the part of the State of
Texas and the men and women of the Texas
Department of Public Safety for the loss
of the victims that died in that
horrific crime that occurred at the
Allen outlet mall on Saturday
we cannot begin to Fathom the pain and
the time it will take to recover from
this but our prayers are with you
I would also like to commend the
response on Saturday
the response to them all shooting was
stellar
we are so blessed that an allen police
officer who took the appropriate action
did what he did when he did it he
undoubtedly saved countless lives if he
hadn't been there I think we'd had a
much more severe situation on top of
that
the agencies that responded
the local agency Sheriff's Office other
PDS the fire department everybody did
what they were supposed to do and
responded to the scene from the DPS
perspective we had Texas Highway Patrol
troopers on the scene within minutes
we dispatched our Texas Rangers to
assist with shooting investigation and
ultimately the Rangers have taken over
the leading investigation in addition we
had our SRT teams aircraft and now to
this point we have our victim Services
counselors on the ground I will tell you
to Governor Abbott through my director
Steve McCraw reached out immediately and
said whatever needs to be done to
support city of Allen this horrific time
to do it all state resources have been
committed
to this effort the Texas Rangers have
been tasked and been put in lead this
investigation it's a very large crime
scene very complex investigation
spanning multiple jurisdictions and the
Rangers along with the local law
enforcement agency Allen PD and our
federal Partners particularly FBI and
ATF are working hand in hand to get the
answers you know many of the answers are
still away from getting to but some
things we do know we have processed the
crime scene as the chief was saying
we've really in the sac was saying we've
released the parking lot 1100 vehicles I
mean it was a big scene we had to clear
it we've done it in pre-record time if
you think about it you're only talking
less than 72 hours ago this event was
occurring and to be this far down the
road I think is very commendable on the
part of all the parties involved the
cooperation between the agencies has
been exceptional and I think it's a
model for the way things should be done
in the future
one thing that we we do know is after
we've identified the shooter and his
name has been made public he's from the
Dallas area so FBI Dallas PD assisted we
ran warrants down on his residence his
actual parents house and I believe Hotel
residents to see what evidence we could
lean from that the FBI has his computers
cell phones and other evidence and
they're in the process of trying to do
digital forensics as the sac mentioned
to go ahead and ascertain what type of
evidence we can get off of that the
shooter had no CCH no criminal history
so we had no documentable criminal
history on him he was in the U.S army
and that's been posted on the media in
2008. he was in basic training I think
early on in basic training they realized
from what I've seen that you know he was
not a fish for the Army and so they
separated him from the Army you know
before he got out of the training mode
there were some questions you know about
his Fitness for Duty that information
will be forthcoming later on as we dig
into the investigation
uh he also had a private security
license
in the state of Texas again he had no
criminal history and the license has
expired I understand he worked as a
security guard for several firms but uh
he was not an active security guard at
the time of this
when we
he had eight weapons with him
he had three on this person and he had
five in his vehicle the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms has run
traces on all the weapons all of the
weapons were legally obtained by the
shooter none of them were stolen
anything else and now we're running
checks on them to see if they were using
any crimes but at this time we haven't
uncovered anything in that regard
the big question that we're dealing with
right now is what's his motive why did
he do this
well the big question is we don't know
that's what the investigation is trying
to find out
we do know that he had Neo-Nazi ideation
he had Patches he had tattoos
even his signature you know verified
that that's one thing we do know
we are trying to get into his computer
and on social media and find out
you know whether he had any anything
that he'd publicized or been out we're
looking around and we're seeing what are
you trying to find we looked at and
trying to get everything information we
can this is the ongoing part of the
investigation and we have a we have a
situation
that once we figure that out hopefully
we figured that out and get definitive
about it we can go public with that down
the road
to me it looks like he targeted the
location
rather than a specific group of people
he was very random in the people he
killed it didn't matter the age
same race or sex he just shot people and
which is horrific in itself
as I said before the investigation is
ongoing
we're gonna the Texas Rangers FBI ATF
and Allen PD as well as any other
agencies assisting us are going to leave
no strong in turn to try to identify
this motive and try to find out whatever
we can at this time we think he acted
alone there's no indication he had any
Confederates or anybody working with him
but we're also keeping an open mind in
that regard too because you never know
um
has the FBI site mentioned our victim
Services the Texas state of Texas victim
Services working hand in hand with the
city of Allen and the FBI to try to
assist these victims to get on the road
to getting their lives back to normal
you know so we're doing what we can and
the information that you need to contact
is there there's also the state of Texas
has a crime victim compensation fund and
we're also trying to plug the people the
victims into that to maybe to help them
get their lives right
okay with that uh
that's all I'm going to brief on right
now again the investigation I'm going
but I will take a couple of questions
well it's too early to say that for sure
you know I mean obviously
circumstantially you might say something
like that but we need to get more into
his ideology get into his social media
and see more than we have
um
I know there's a website out there I
haven't personally seen it I know the
FBI and the Texas Rangers are looking
into that and that's something that's
another part of the investigation we're
looking at
this point there's been any kind of
Manifesto or anything like that that
you've found not to my knowledge
yes
not to my knowledge I don't have the
names of the companies you work for and
I don't know if he worked at that
location he hasn't worked in the
security business for a while
I do not know 100 where he worked
so so I believe the event was like three
to four minutes from the time that the
first shots were fired I think it was
337 or something like that and we're
looking at uh uh I think within three or
four minutes the Allen PD officer had
neutralized the suspect
and the shooting stopped and there's no
indication anybody else was was shooting
besides him and the officer
given what he was posting on social
media was he on law enforcement's radar
at all
not to my knowledge
last question
um
echoing the public here is there any way
that you think you can protect the
public from the next mass shooting if
anyone a suspect like this man who we
know was discharged from the military
over mental health concerns can go out
and purchase an arm load of firearms
well that's a very difficult question
and uh
uh he was in the military in 2008 and a
recording reporting requirements were a
lot different back then than they are
now
and even if he couldn't have purchased
these firearms legally he probably could
have obtained them illegally or used
some other vehicle literally a vehicle
to perpetrate something similar you know
it's uh when you have people with mental
illness if this if it turns out that
this gentleman has that uh when you have
that situation they will find a way
uh sometimes yes
no no he he legally every weapon he
purchased was legal so thank you
thank you